British prime minister Liz truss has
resigned after just six weeks in office
her announcement comes after a bruising
week of u-turns on economic and energy
policy and a backlash from her own
conservative party
in a short speech outside Downing Street
trust said she can no longer deliver on
the Mandate for which she was elected
I came into office
to economic and international
instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's a legal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
I recognize though given the situation I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
our correspondent bigot Moss is standing
by for us in London bigot Liz truss has
announced her resignation after just 45
days in office as prime minister how did
it come to this
a very short stand for this trusses here
in Downing Street just behind me and
very very dramatically she has said that
she is going to design to resign to
office we are experiencing really the
implosion of their conservative party as
we have known it she's the second prime
minister
um this year and she somebody who wasn't
elected she had to she was basically the
replacement of Boris Johnson who
disgracefully had to resign and now she
does not command the authority of her
party anymore basically there are deep
divisions within the conservative party
Liz truss lost the authority because she
wasn't able to get her budget through
that was her whole plan she stood for a
quite aggressive tax cuts those have
spooked the markets and created Chaos on
the financial markets and that really uh
brought things uh it and brought it into
rolling so she was not able basically to
to have expect of her own MPS and so no
other option as to resign
so her policies obviously didn't go down
well but Britain's conservatives
themselves have been tearing themselves
apart why are they so divided
yes really they have and traditionally
they are seen as the party of economic
competence this is what they have been
priding themselves in but we have seen
over the last decades that something was
eroding the conservative party from
within and that was the issue of Europe
it has divided the party between a
moderate sort of Centrist and broadly
pro-european wing and another Wing which
was more libertarian and those people
made sure that the UK left the EU on on
really the the strongest of and hardest
of brexit with just a free trade
agreement and and but really bare bone
and it's these people that are the
moderates are are fighting this trust is
somebody who comes from the libertarian
small state wing of the party and now
she's been ousted by MPS mostly by the
moderate MPS but even people to the
right of the party she had lost their
trust too
so where does this leave British
politics very good what what happens
next
it's until a successor is found and that
should happen rather quickly however we
are already seeing the opposition the
liberal Democrats and labor they are
demanding that there should be a general
election because let's trust ourselves
uh Was Not Elected by the British people
and in a situation like this where there
is an economic crisis like other
countries the UK is facing High
inflation it's facing high energy Crisis
crisis and that is a very tough
situation for for a lot of people a lot
of people can't afford to eat to heat
their homes they really are on the
breadline and and they're in Dire
Straits so labor and the liberal
Democrats are demanding that
when the country is in such a tricky
situation economically that the British
people should have a choice as to which
party now leads the country hopefully
out of the crisis
any idea Burgett who might take over
from Liz trust as a conservative party
leader and prime minister
well so far we have only had
they are not going to take over Jeremy
Hunter is the newly appointed chancellor
has excluded himself The Hope was in the
last days that the conservative MPS
could find a candidate who they can
unite behind or even a team that they
can unite behind but as we're seeing
with such a divided party as proof it's
proved very very tricky and so far no
name that MPS can unite behind has
emerged
very good thank you so much for now that
was our correspondent bigot moss in
London